[MUSIC PLAYING]
SULI ALI: We wake up every
morning with excitement
to make games that
make people happy.
Our mission as a company is to
make people happy five minutes
at a time.
Building on different
devices is hard
for a couple different reasons.
We have devices of
different screen sizes.
We also have devices of
different hardware capacity,
and we want to make sure
that we have experiences that
are incredibly immersive
on tablet devices,
so you can play in the living
room, forget all about your TV,
and just play our games
in the living room.
And we also want to
make sure that if you're
on a bus on a phone that
you bought two years ago
our game still runs
incredibly well.
And the way we deal with that
from a technology perspective
is we built our own
game engine, and we
built our own
interface builder that
allows us to treat UI
for our games like UI
on the web, where the UI
scales to fit the screen
size dynamically, and we
adjust the frames per second
in animations based on the
type of device that you use.